there was a debate uh this debate went
viral online between two Muslims and uh
two well uh known and famous Islam
haters one of them is from the Arab
world and one of them is from the
Western
World they met each
other met each other mean the two
enemies of Islam one of these name
Robert Spencer the other one
rashidi rashidi this person or Hami is
known to be a liar and alhamdulillah
many our brothers many brothers from the
Arab world have exposed him refused him
uh and showed with a clear proves uh
he's a liar rather there are some
brothers and I do agree with them they
say this person he must be an atheist he
just utilizing Christianity to make
money out of it just as just like the
other person he's well known as well um
call this kab a liar Christian Prince
this man he's a atheist hidden atheist
he's making a money from the Christians
because Christianity is dying
Christianity is dying no doubt about it
is dying in a countries uh were known to
go out their way to look to to convert
people to force Christianity upon people
which is the Western World they came to
Africa Asia South America Australia
Canada to force people to become
Christians the same people have
abandoned Christianity rather theion of
War angers Christianity and other
religions so the Shah the the the the
point here is my dear brothers and
sisters may Allah bless you all that in
this debate there was some doubt thrown
out and uh the brothers du to that's why
I just want to make something clear
that's why I don't like when I speak to
people try to control the time say I
will give you two minutes you have I
mean you have two minutes two minutes so
the problem with this type of discussion
di dialect that in his own two minutes
he will be able to do anything and you
cannot pin him down and you know my
style I'm let you tell me your life
story I'm going to pin you down
regardless what you going to say are you
cutting me you interrupting me you rude
say whatever you like you know moveing
because my point here to expose your
lies and if you are sincere to refuse
the doubt and and to to establish the
truth I'm not here to entertain no
one the sh my dear brothers and sisters
may Allah bless you all one of the doubt
that many Christians utilizes and
enemies of Islam utilizes to uh
to try to refute or uh make Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam look
bad or Islam The Story of B B this um
tribe from the yood that lived in Medina
so what is their story when came to
Medina the the
the the other tribes of the yahood uh
sign up a treaty the treaty is that if
an enemy from outside tried to come
invade Medina it's upon all of us to
come together and defend it okay they
have the they signed it they were not
forced in the time
of the B of when the the Arabs came
together the Pagan Arabs came together
against the Muslims in Medina and they
besieged
Medina uh
so who is behind them is the behind the
Muslims are the B Ben signed up and gu
and side against
gu with Arab pagans all right
so the news reached him that has broken
the the treaty and it's one established
even our time that if a country break
the Treaty of peace that is a sign of
war the war is is going to
begin uh so what
happened he said let me double check so
he sent some of his companions to double
check and they found out yes it is that
they did broke uh they did break the the
peace treaty so after he uh finished
with the the Arab pagans he went to them
he beseeched them and they said B said
we're not happy with anyone judgment
because we want to submit all right we
going to surrender but we're not happy
with no one judgment except one person
who is that person someone one was the
Allies he was the Ally of he was the
Ally of um the yood more specifically
the tribe of B so said
okay they said we are happy with his
judgment we are happy with what with his
judgment so it was notam gave the
judgment and never forced them to choose
someone they chose someone willingly
they said we not happy with you oh
Muhammad to give us a
judgment came he said oh messenger of
Allah if I pass on a judgment ever will
be happy with it they said
yes so he said the judgment is to kill
the adults and to take their women and
their children as a war
booty a person might say that's very
harsh why are you doing this to the yood
because in our time the Y
become a criteria to test people if
you're a good person or bad person if
you love The yahood you're the most
excellent person now CH not lgbtq no
more y the enemies of Islam they always
try to utilize something to make Islam
look bad before was the Jewish people
even though we know who was killing je
Jewish people in Andalusia and what
happened to Jewish people when they came
to us in andalia or when they were
andalia the Spain and Portugal who took
care of them protect them that that
doesn't mean there was not some bad
Muslims that harmed the Jewish people
likewise historically many times Jewish
people oppressed killed raped many
people and many tribes all right so
Jewish people are not criteria for us to
test us if we are good or bad let I'll
make that subject
clear and no one is a
criteria no one is a criteria for our
Prophet
Muhammad if he good or bad here's the
criteria whoever oppose the messenger of
Allah is bad either intentionally or
unintentionally if it's intentionally C
if he's a Muslim if he the of Islam is
from the ad of Islam if he
unintentionally we clarify the truth to
him anyway anyway my dear brothers and
sisters many people don't know the
Judgment of is in the
Bible was given to it was given to
Jewish people so if you have a problem
with that judgment then you have a
problem with with the Jewish people and
the scripture so you anti samite you see
you going to be anti-site you see how we
turn the table against you let us here
in theonomy law concerning War so uh
page 21 20 the chapter in chapter 20 the
verse or the passage start from 10 when
you go near a city to fight and guest it
then Proclaim an offer of peace to it
and it shall be that if they accept you
offer of peace and open to you then all
the people who are found in it shall be
placed under uh tribute to you and serve
you islamically that's not the same if
they open for us then we know Allah we
give them the the their right okay if
they uh uh accept the peace treaty then
that's it we cannot take they take as a
servant and so on no we don't do that
but according to to the Torah they allow
it to do that but no one speaks about it
Islam hat it where are you no no no and
now it's the Muslims the target not the
Jewish people anyway it goes on say now
if the city will not make peace with you
but makes war against you so here so
here what is it you take them as a
servant everything Belongs to You person
might say what about killing the the
there is in the other passages that if
you conquer a city uh which is in uh
Leviticus uh then you kill the man and
the woman that s to the man and keep the
Little Ghost for you that's one of the
the the the the war rules in in judaic
law in the Torah all right then he goes
on saying not if the city will not make
peace with you but makes a war against
you then you should besiege it and when
the Lord God delivers it into your hand
you should strike every Mo in it with
the edge of the sought by the woman the
little ones the the the the the the
livestock and all that is in the
city all is spoiled you shall plunder
for yourselves and you should eat the
enemy's uh plunder which the Lord your
God gives gives
you then he goes on say but of the of
the cities of these people uh that's you
okay uh
thus you should do to all the cities
which are very far from you which are
not of the cities of these nations but
all of the cities of these uh peoples
which the Lord your God gives you as an
inheritance you shall let nothing that
breathes remain
alive
nothing not if you bese another city so
they depends on the cities yeah there
are some cities don't let nothing that
breef to be alive children wom so now
thisi an atheist is's not a Christian is
atheist is known he's going against the
Bible you know say no but we don't
follow the Old Testament the point here
is when God commanded this was he evil
God or was he a good God so the problem
that you have is not the Islamic law you
have a problem is that commandment in
the Islamic law is it from God or not
that's why everything boils down to what
is Islam from God so it's pointless try
to hide behind try to utilize emotional
argument because you're heavily
influenced by atheism and liberalism you
know like I said these people are
atheists hiding behind Christianity
because they are making the money out of
it so this doubt this ruling or judgment
that was given to them by the messenger
of Allah said yeah said your uh judgment
coincide with Allah judgment the score
is mentioned is the meaning of this what
is the meaning of the Prophet statement
meaning that judgment is in the Torah as
well Subhan Allah so you're going to be
anti-site if you disagree
with because that is in their books so
either you have to reject
everything okay and be anti-site anti
the Muslims or openly say you're a clown
and a double standard atheist liar enemy
of God legislation not just Islamic
legislation God legislation was given to
a prophet and messenger you just a liar
who are utilizing Christianity to make
money out of it because Christianity is
dying and some Christians are looking
for anyone to save them so they don't
mind if if if even if that person is
open atheist clearly that they don't
care they don't care may Allah bless you
all my dear brothers and sisters and
maybe we make more videos clarifying
some doubt that was thrown out by this
evil liar evil Liars may Allah bless you
all and alhamdulillah Muslims upon the
Sunnah and may Allah give us sincerity
and